TO CHARLES TO BE THAT SAME KIND
OF UNIFYING FORCE IN THIS
COUNTRY, ERIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FROM WINDSOR.
I WANT TO BRING IN DARREN
McGRADY BECAUSE HE SERVED AS
PERSONAL CHEF TO QUEEN ELIZABETH
AND HER FAMILY FOR 15 YEARS.
DARREN, I'M SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS.
THIS IS PERSONAL FOR YOU.
YOU TRAVELED THE WORLD WITH THE
QUEEN AND HER FAMILY FOR MORE
THAN A DECADE.
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER MOST ABOUT
HER?
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
SAD DAY.
I'M FEELING THOSE PAINS IN MY
STOMACH AS IF I'D LOST A LOVED
ONE.
I THINK THE WHOLE NATION FEELS
THE SAME AND EVERYONE AROUND THE
WORLD.
I GOT TO SEE THE QUEEN FOR ALL
THOSE YEARS AND POMP AND
PAGEANTRY BUT ALSO BEHIND THE
SCENES TOO, THE HAPPY, SMILING
FACES.
I'M THINKING BACK TO WHEN I
FIRST MET HER, WALKING THE
CORGIS ALONG THE RIVER BY
BALMORAL CASTLE.
THE CORGIS CHASING ME, AND ME
RUNNING AWAY.
THE QUEEN LAUGHING OUT LOUD.
I'VE SEEN HER DANCING AT
BALMORAL AND JUST SEEN THE HAPPY
TIMES.
THOSE YEARS WHERE I COOKED
BREAKFAST, LUNCH, AFTERNOON TEA
AND DINNER FOR THE MOST AMAZING
LADY.
>> YOU CALL HER THE MOST AMAZING
LADY, AND YOU TALK ABOUT HER
HUMOR.
IT HAS BEEN, YOU KNOW, AMIDST
THE SADNESS AND SERIOUSNESS OF
TODAY, SOME OF THE STORIES OF
HER HUMOR WOULD MAKE ANYONE
LAUGH.
I MEAN A WONDERFUL SENSE OF
HUMOR SHE HAD.
SHE HAD ACCESS TO ANYTHING SHE
WANTED, RIGHT?
ANYTHING SHE WANTED.
YOU SAW THAT, OF COURSE, WITH
FOOD.
YOU'RE COOKING BREAKFAST, LUNCH,
TEA, DINNER, ANYTHING.
BUT YOU SAY SHE WASN'T A FOODIE.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO WORK FOR
HER, TO COOK FOR HER?
>> WHEN I FIRST STARTED WORKING
AT THE PALACE, I THOUGHT THIS IS
IT.
WE'RE GOING TO BE HAVING
CHAMPAGNE AND CAVIAR AND FOIE
GRAS EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
BUT THAT WASN'T THE CASE.
THE QUEEN WAS VERY HUMBLE.
SHE IS QUITE HAPPY JUST DOING A
STATE BANQUET WHERE WE HAVE TO
HAVE ALL THOSE RICH FOODS ON THE
MENU WHEN SHE'S ENTERTAINING
KINGS, QUEENS, PRESIDENTS AROUND
THE WORLD.
I COOKED FOR FIVE DIFFERENT
PRESIDENTS WHILE I WAS THERE.
BUT WHEN SHE WAS ON HER OWN,
JUST GRILLED FISH, GRILLED
CHICKEN.
SHE WAS NEVER HAPPIER THAN WHEN
SHE WAS ACTUALLY EATING
SOMETHING FROM HER OWN GARDEN.
SOME VEGETABLES, SOMETHING THAT
HER AND PRINCESS MARGARET HAD
PICKED FROM THE CAGES OF
BALMORAL CASTLE.
THAT'S WHEN SHE WAS HAPPY.
>> YOU WERE ALSO PRINCESS
DIANA'S FORMAL PERSONAL CHEF FOR
SEVERAL YEARS BEFORE HER TRAGIC
DEATH.
I KNOW YOU HELD INFANT PRINCE
HARRY WHILE DIANA ATE CEREAL IN
THE KITCHEN.
WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
HOW WAS WORKING FOR HER, AND I
KNOW OF COURSE IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN QUITE DIFFERENT THAN
WORKING WITH THE QUEEN.
>> YEAH, IT DID CROSS MY MINDING
TODAY WHEN I'M SEEING ALL OF
THESE PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE FLOWERS
BUILDING UP OUTSIDE WINDSOR
CASTLE, BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
I WAS THE PRINCESS CHEF RIGHT UP
UNTIL THE DAY, WAITING FOR HER
TO RETURN THE NEXT DAY.
SEEING OUTFRONT OF KENSINGTON
PALACE, THOSE FLOWERS BUILDING
UP AND THE PEOPLE OUT THERE ALL
THROUGH THE NIGHT.
THIS IS JUST MEMORIES OF TWO
PEOPLE THAT CREATED A DIFFERENCE
IN THE WORLD AND TOUCHED SO MANY
PEOPLE.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING
THE TIME A